statistics and data are at the heart of
the fight against kofig 19. they were
used to justify
england's second lockdown and they'll
probably guide us when it's lifted as
well
we can talk now to the government's most
senior advisor on statistics
in diamond thank you very much for being
on the programme this morning
so i want to start with the question
that everyone wants to know the answer
to
how prevalent is coronavirus in the uk
right now and are there any signs that
the speed at which it's spreading
is beginning to slow well the good news
let's start with the good news the good
news is yes we
are seeing a slow down in the rate of
growth
that means we're still increasing uh and
we are now
in england at around about 1.25 per
thousand that means that one in 85
people in england
we believe have the virus in wales a
little less at 1 in 100 scotland
135 northern ireland one 105.
so yes we are continuing to increase
the rate we're increasing the numbers
but the rate of growth is slowing
can you give us any um detail on who it
is who
is most likely to have coronavirus and
whereabouts they might be
yes well in england we have huge uh
regional uh variation um
we have seen uh in the the northwest
northeast and in yorkshire
um steady increases although they have
tended to flatten off
in recent weeks a little it's
now seen increases in in the last week
in the east midlands west midlands uh
and and the southeast
and rates are lower although slightly
increasing in the rest of the country
and then where has that been happening
well uh amongst younger people those
in their teenagers and early adults was
where this wave
started it's now moved into all age
groups
although again to finish with some good
news the good news is that amongst those
teenagers and younger adults
we are seeing some reductions at the
moment
it really is so refreshing to hear that
at least there is a bit of good news it
feels like there's been so many
interviews over the last
nine months where all we've had is the
kind of gloomiest statistics possible
and given the fact that although as you
say it's still spreading the rate
is slowing slightly do you think we are
on track to leave the lockdown in
england on the 2nd of december oh
sophie that's the sixty-four thousand
dollar question and um
i would love to give you an answer um we
we moved into this new period of
restrictions just a short while ago what
you'd expect to see
in the initial period of restrictions is
a continued increase very simply
because these are infections that people
would have caught
before the restrictions started we will
be working tirelessly
over the next couple of weeks to to
monitor how
the restrictions are working in
impacting
on the pandemic and we have
towards the end of the restrictions to
to provide
all the very best data we can to the
government to
help ministers with what will clearly be
a very difficult decision
um it's interesting isn't it because
some of the statistics suggest that the
virus was already slowing
before we went into the lockdown you
know the r number for example which
measures how many people each infected
person passes the virus to
it's been falling since the middle of
october we know that it's one to 1.2 now
but of course there's a lag it measures
what was happening a couple of weeks ago
so if the rate was already falling did
we need to look down at all
well i think we need to recognize that
uh that the r
number which has let's be clear uh a
a degree of uncertainty around it uh in
any time
you know we look at one number but
there's always a lower and upper limit
remains above one when it remains above
one
it means that we are continuing to
increase
and let's be also clear in different
parts of the country
that the rates were pretty high already
so they're pretty high already and
they're still
continuing to increase albeit at a lower
level they're getting bigger
so i don't think there was too much um
debate that the government had a
difficult but made the right call
okay and now throughout the pandemic
we've become so used to these
press conferences where the government
shows us very detailed slides
um of data but there's been some
criticism about the data that they show
that it's quite hard to unpick
have you been concerned at all that the
government's been effectively
self-selecting the data
that it shows us to back up their
arguments no i i couldn't
um support that sophie i'd have to say
uh during the the first wave some of my
colleagues were
embedded into uh the heart of government
to
make sure that the quality
of the presentations that were made to
the public were at the highest level
i think it's incredibly important my
experience and my conversations
throughout this pandemic with government
has been a real
wish right across government for
openness and for transparency
we at the office international
statistics do everything
we can to to support that and some of my
colleagues
will now be going back into the heart of
government really to work on making sure
that the communication of statistics
that
the graphs you may see are at the
highest possible level
you said uh that that you were quite
confident with the first wave
but that your colleagues were only just
going back in have you had any concerns
about
the way that data's been presented
during the second week then
we we at the ins have been really
working tirelessly to make sure that
openness and transparency
is at the heart of what we uh
do we have a real policy at ons that we
only talk about data
which are in uh the public domain
and i know that that commitment to
openness and transparency goes right
across government
um okay the uk uk statistics authority
which you had said earlier this month
the use of data has not consistently
been supported by transparent
information being provided in a timely
manner
as a result there is a potential to
confuse the public and undermine
confidence
in the statistics can you explain what
some of those concerns are
sophia i i hate to um get involved in a
technical point but i think you're
referring to
um a some work by the regulator the
office for statistical
regulation which was with the chair
of the uk statistics authority sir david
norgrove
i am the national statistician
we believe it's really incredibly
important that the regulator is
independent
and the work you're quoting is from the
independent regulator
okay and one of the areas where um the
government hasn't been completely
transparent should we say is over
compliance it's been quite hard to
get any information on how many people
are following the rules which clearly uh
you know is absolutely critical in the
fight against clover19
do you have any uh data on compliance
that's a really really good question
another important one if i may say so
sophie
and yes we run a weekly um
opinions and lifestyle survey which
talks uh
about things like you know are you
wearing um
face masks it talks about uh social
isolation or indeed
are you meeting with other families and
what we find particularly in those tier
three
areas was a really high degree of
compliance
uh with the
regulations and the restrictions that
were imposed in those areas we found a
very very high proportion of people
wearing face masks now that not to say
that everybody
is and i think one of the things i would
say is it is incredibly important you
know i might say to you
95 of people are reporting
wearing face masks and that is a big
statistic that's that's the statistic we
have
but at the same time that still says
that five percent
are not and the five percent of a very
big number like the population of
england
is still a reasonably big number so we
need to be
absolutely tireless in promoting the
restrictions but the very good news here
is that from the data that we have um on
on the
on adherence there then
then people are really adhering to the
restrictions i would have to say
um that we have less information uh on
um proportions of people uh say
self-isolating and that's work that we
will be
trying to improve our data on in the
short
time really interesting stuff as you say
an important part of the battle against
kovid
i'm keen to talk to you uh just before
we end about the economy the ons of
course
measures uh economic growth and we've
seen some quite encouraging figures more
recently
but of course we're now in in a lockdown
and how
concerned are you about the economic
recovery
well we've all got to be concerned about
the economic recovery let me start by
saying that the long-term
future of the economy is inextricably
linked
with getting on top of the pandemic and
that's that
i think that's the key thing but yes we
have seen three months
of growth in our gdp but again
it's been mixed uh it wouldn't be a
surprise
to you if i said look where we've seen
growth uh in the economy
has been in places like couriers and
computer repair
in in retail driven of course uh by
online
but with at the same time really uh
still major
um slow downs relative to to february
in transport in tourism and in the
creative industries one of the jewels in
our crowd
which are down uh 61 percent on their
that their place in february so the
position on the economy i would have to
say
is mix yes we have had some growth but
it is in
uh different sectors um and i would have
to say
that we have around seven hundred
thousand people uh
less uh on the payroll uh now than
we did uh yeah i'll pass on the payroll
on payrolls
uh now uh than we did in
february um but at the same time
uh there have been uh our our reading
of the number of vacancies is that they
did increase
although in the most recent period they
they have plateaued a little bit
so so it's a very mixed uh story on the
economy
but key to getting the economy back
flowing is getting on top of the
pandemic
okay uh certain diamond always really
good to talk and thank you so much for
coming the program this morning
always good to see you sophie